une production du studio SF
bien nous enfiltre le podcast où on
parle tout ce qu'on veut que nous
inviter date site pH Quentin avec moi
big banglant lui-même en chair et en os
le foie gras
cette semaine on reçoit Mélina Roberge
qui est quelqu'un que vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler
en fait
[Musique]
laissez-moi vous
Mélina ce qui s'est passé c'est cassé
fait arrêter en Australie
pour trafic de cacaine en fait à la
vaisselle dans ses bagages à faire une
croisière autour du monde puis était
débarqué le pied ça fait arrêter puis à
le fait 5 ans de prison en Australie ce
qui est pas rien à 22 ans
mais donc dans le podcast on parle de
cette histoire de comment ça le marquer
qu'est-ce qu'il a amené premièrement à
accepter à se retrouver dans cette
situation-là comment qu'elle a le vécu
son séjour en prison comment qui a vie
maintenant après qu'est-ce qu'elle a
appris dans toute
sa processus
[Musique]
envie de partager en fait que appris
beaucoup de choses puis qu'il y a eu des
grandes leçons de vie avec ceux puis que
envie de partager pour éviter à d'autres
de commettre les mêmes erreurs en fait à
Triel
quelqu'un qui est vraiment beaucoup de
choses à dire sur en fait plusieurs
sujets c'était vraiment super encore une
fois une histoire incroyable
quelque chose une épreuve comme un peu
peu de gens en vivent en fait là donc
je pense que vous allez mettre ça je
commence comme moi j'adorais puis c'est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment une facilité
aussi avec la communication qui est
vraiment foule entre gens full Nice
foldophone tu es vraiment un grand
plaisir ouais puis une bonne petite
réflexion sur sur le paraître
puisqu'on voit ces réseaux sociaux ce
qui est un peu ce qu'il a amené dans ce
chemin là entre autres
superbes belle conversation son livre
est disponibles son livre ben oui sans
ironie s'appelle sans filtre c'est quoi
les chances c'est quoi les chances on
discutait un petit peu avant le podcast
puis
les raisons pour laquelle sont les
s'appelait sans fil sont sensiblement
les mêmes que que nous en fait
initialement que pendant un seul projet
quand on a lancé le projet est en prison
c'est foutu de dire ça même c'est même
c'est long c'est quand même c'est une
grosse trunky de ta vie de temps en plus
on va aller on va bon podcast en fait
profiter de la conversation c'est
vraiment on vient de l'avoir la
conversation c'est c'est du gros stock
là même c'est pas c'est pas rien
bonne écoute puis profitez-en le podcast
de cette semaine est présenté par nos
amis chez men's Kate men skate c'est la
compagnie par excellence pour
l'entretien de la peau des poils des
autres de la pilosité de des odeurs
c'est ma compagnie de de soins pour la
peau préférée moi j'utilise le shampoing
et le bas des wash à tout toutes mes
douches puis là je dis tout j'allais
dire tous les jours mais
c'est pas vrai que je prends une douche
à tous les jours je prends une douche
presque tous les jours mais pas tous les
jours des fois il y a des jours que je
skate la douche des journées de même
leur odeur caractéristique mais Skype
est incroyable et on l'odeur dans le
parfum dans le déo dans toutes les
produits
le Wild Waker
j'aime ça c'est en fait c'est faux c'est
pour la gestion des poils de narines des
poils des oreilles moi je m'en sers
vraiment beaucoup pour mes narines trois
par semaine donc un petit coup de Wind
Waker vous regardez ça bien clean moi
j'aime pas ça avoir des des poils de nez
qui dépassent trop personnellement je
suis une préférence donc Will Rock You
j'aime bien ça sinon le fameux la pièce
maîtresse si vous voulez demain Skype
c'est le Love là on est rendu au
quatrième édition de la mort 4.0 c'est
tout simplement le meilleur endroit
électrique que vous allez jamais
utiliser et waterproof peut l'amener
dans la douche il est vraiment
il restait il y a rien qui reste poignée
dedans
on a un code promo pour vous pour tous
les produits manscape toutes les
packages qu'on a devant nous allez voir
sur leur site notre code pour 20% de
rabais puis le shipping gratuit ce qui
est considérable que merci monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais ça roule ça roule salut
comment ça va le lancement
hier est venue nous faire un souper chez
nous parce qu'à sentait que j'avais
besoin de relaxer en fait 40 minutes de
route juste pour des nouvelles aspect
puis j'ai habité comment tu as trouvé ça
pas j'ai dit je pense qu'en fin de
semaine je vais laisser mon sel chez
nous je dois partir comme une journée ou
deux tout seul ou avec mon jump peu
importe
parce que j'ai dit on dirait que dans le
temps mettons en 2016 où les années
précédentes j'aurais été contente
d'avoir tout cette attention là puis que
que le monde sache qui puis que j'ai des
nouveaux followers puis on dirait que là
ça
c'est comme c'est comme amer dans ma
bouche je sais pas comment expliquer là
mais j'ai hâte que ça soit fini puis que
je puisse en retourner à ma petite vie
normale même si c'est ironique là je
viens d'écrire un livre avec
claudemment de devenir une personne
publique en
écrivains même quand j'ai pris la
décision de le faire je pense j'ai pas
réalisé dans quoi je m'embarquais à 100%
là jusqu'à ce que ça sorte cette semaine
et puis c'est en liaison avec plein de
choses je veux dire il y a eu plein de
beaux commentaires mais aussi plein de
commentaires de merde que faut que tu
dises avec ça puis c'est pas
moi quand je suis arrivé en 2016 j'ai
pas vu la vague de négativité qui est
arrivé parce que j'étais déjà
j'étais plus serrés réseaux sociaux puis
ma famille gérait mes réseaux tes fax
que c'est les autres quand on se parlait
au téléphone ma mère elle devenait un
peu
12 podcast personnel quelqu'un que je
t'allais occupation d'eux on s'en
parlait avant
mon ils nous ont fait ils ont parti un
compte puis après comment ça marche
comme 130 000 abonnés puis j'avais mon
autre compte personnel que les gens
c'était quand même abonné parce que
parce que personnel qui était rendu à
10000 abonnés on va on va le filer
mais non mais les commentaires négatifs
c'est c'est pour c'est pire pour
l'entourage moi je trouve en tout cas
personnellement
c'est ton entourage qui qui ont pas
mettons premièrement qui ont pas mérité
ça pas que personne mérite des
commentaires négatifs mais donc ils sont
pas la cause des commentaires négatifs
puis qui les regarde puis ça les touches
bien plus que toi
c'est que j'ai fait de pas correct dans
mon parent pour que ma fille finisse en
prison c'est deux des convaincre c'est
pas toute leur faute
puis ma mère m'a protégée de beaucoup de
choses quand j'étais jeune puis ça c'est
c'est aucune maladie il y a rien qui est
arrivé dans tout ça qui est de sa faute
mais ma mère elle adore ses enfants à 8
pour ses enfants a fait tout encore
aujourd'hui en fonction de ses enfants
ça que je pense que quand j'étais jeune
j'étais un petit peu trop rebelle à son
goût puis elle voulait me protéger il
faut que souvent m'empêcher d'aller
faire des activités mettons d'aller voir
des amis parce qu'à les connaissait pas
et elle connaissait pas l'adresse puis
je voulais rien savoir de donner facté
puis on dirait le plus que je me faisais
empêcher le plus que je voulais c'est
briser la corde puis aller voir de mes
propres yeux je pense que ça va durer
quand même longtemps ça puis j'ai jamais
rien ma mère j'étais super tu es
vraiment dans ma bulle j'étais pas là la
fille que je suis aujourd'hui là
maintenant que ouais je cherchais je me
cherchais je me cherchais beaucoup puis
on se pose jamais vraiment de questions
quand on est jeune c'est du goût de flow
puis t'atterrissent que tu as intérêt
[Musique]
mais je me suis jamais demandé pourquoi
je veux ça je pense que c'est l'erreur
que beaucoup de gens font c'est que
justement on est coaching notre vie à
regarder des images puis il y a des
images qu'on dit ouais ça c'est de la
pauvreté puis le monde ne sont pas
contents quand ils font juste je sais
pas moi 40 000 par année puis ça c'est
la richesse puis regarde comment elles
sont heureux regarde les enfants comment
qui sourit regarde comment que tu peux
partir en vacances quand tu veux ça
qu'on a quand même été un peu coacher
puis malheureusement tu sais je suis pas
né avec un téléphone d'elle-même mais ça
a pas été très long après que la
technologie est arrivée puis j'avais
accès à Internet tout ça puis c'est pas
mettons avant mon adolescence que là
instagram est né puis qu'on a commencé à
voir c'est des images tout ça puis la
différence
dans le tapis aujourd'hui moi j'étais je
me suis chanteur quand je suis revenu à
quel point il s'est rendu important pour
tout le monde mais
maintenant que oui mais en même temps
Instagram peut être utilisé si vous êtes
vous vous utilisez pour des excellentes
raisons on fait des podcasts vous
interviews du monde intéressant mais
c'est ça puis dans le temps on dirait
que je voulais du luxe parce que c'est
ça que j'avais appris qui était beau
dans la vie puis je me mets avec des des
j'ai toujours été en fait avec des gens
plus vieux parce que j'aimais pas
peut-être la mentalité déjà de mon âge
où il y avait pas justement la vision
que moi j'avais
mais malheureusement aussi ça m'a amené
à me tenir avec des gens qui faisaient
de l'argent facile pas criminel mais
facile
puis moi je voulais ça mais je voulais
pas faire ce qu'il faisait ta vie c'est
ça qu'on dirait c'était tout le temps un
manque un manque puis au STO que je
faisais de l'argent je la dépensais puis
je regardais pas comme un plat financier
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ou je peux
tu me trouver un autre job sur le côté
que je fais dans mon dans mes temps
libre qui peut me rapporter plus ou
est-ce que je change de job puis que je
vais avoir tendresse je travaillais
parce qu'il faut que tu travailles dans
la vie mais je me suis jamais arrêté
pour me dire c'est qu'est-ce que
j'aimerais faire dans la vie pour être
heureuse
j'ai je regarde un podcast d'un autre
gars qui est parti de rien puis qui est
vraiment millionnaire aujourd'hui mais
il voulait pas être millionnaire c'est
juste qu'il y a fait une job qui a
apporté de l'argent puis qu'aujourd'hui
il rendu là puis lui il disait j'ai
ouais puis je pense c'est ça qui est
important aussi quand tu travailles
c'est que tu travailles pour avoir un
salaire de 1 million faut que tu
travailles puis que tu adores que tu
fais puis que si ça t'apporte un million
ben tant mieux
puis lui il disait moi j'écoutais une
histoire c'est une famille qui avait un
cheval puis attaché le cheval après une
chaise de patio pendant des années le
cheval t'attacha appréciable de passer
ou puis c'est pas que la chasse de
passer au pèse même pas une livre qui
pourrait juste partir quand il veut
mettre toute sa vie il reste là attaché
jusqu'à tant que mettons une heure par
jour la famille elle détache play se
promener mais il revient puis là puis
lui il dit moi je me suis dit c'est quoi
moi ma chaise de passer ou dans la vie
qu'est-ce qui m'empêche d'avancer c'est
quoi qui me retiens tout le temps puis
tu quelque chose qui
puis dis-moi j'ai réalisé que c'était ma
confiance en moi enfin qui dit je me
suis souvent moi-même cinq personnes
d'autres me dise moi je me rabaissais me
dire mettons je sais pas j'aimerais ça
que pilote d'avion mais je me
rappellerai jamais toutes les boutons
puis je me suis rendu compte que moi
aussi ça a été ça toute ma vie puis ça
c'est mes parents c'est les premiers à
me dire ouais on va vite essayer puis
mais j'avais zéro confiance en moi
pourquoi je me suis jamais posé la
question dans le temps je me suis jamais
dit pourquoi j'essaye pas c'est
automatique je me donne je serais pas
capable puis pour pallier à ce manque de
confiance en toi là c'est là que tu
tends vers le paraître mais ton puis
vers l'excès puis le luxe puis je pense
que depuis que j'étais jeune je sentais
que je pouvais pas j'étais juste j'ai
jamais été bonne à l'école parce que je
me suis jamais forcée c'est pas parce
que j'étais pas intelligente mais toute
ma vie j'ai passé j'étais pas bonne à
l'école
puis j'ai eu de la discuter avec mon
poids quand j'étais jeune je me suis
jamais trouvé belle puis pour commencer
à perdre du poids j'ai découvert la
drogue en pilule passer tout ça j'en ai
pris me tente de secondaire 3 secondaire
puis ça fait pas ça parce que c'est pas
mais moi je trouve moi je pensais dans
ma tête que ça m'aidait à l'école
oh mon dieu ah ça c'est drôle
mettez la drogue sera jamais la vraie
porte de sortie intelligente à prendre
dans la vie on s'entend mais j'ai perdu
du poids jusqu'à un point que je portais
du 00 dans mes pantalons puis je suis
flottais à un moment donné mes amis ont
fait quand même
puis il y a quelqu'un dans ma famille
qu'on voyait pas très très souvent qui
est allé voir ma mère un moment donné
parce que je l'explique dans le livre
aussi est allé voir ma mère mais en fait
elle est venue nous visiter puis quand
elle m'a vu elle m'a va dans ta chambre
puis j'étais là
je descendu en bas puis moi et en moi
j'ai écouté ce qu'il disait puis à ma
mère comment tu peux pas voir ta fille a
dégringole pistolet là ça fait deux mois
je l'ai pas vu je pense que a perdu la
moitié du poids qu'elle avait il y a 2
mois c'est parce que maintenant je
consommais je mangeais pas de déjeuner
pour dîner je prenais l'argent avec ma
mère m'a donné mon lunch pour acheter ma
drogue parce que comme ça c'était pas
cher le temps là ça coûtait rien puis
pour souper j'arrivais chez nous j'étais
comme j'avais pas faim parce que ça
coupait l'appétit ce genre de droglov
enfin que je mangeais un bol avec des
cocons notamment des champignons
j'allais me coucher puis c'était ça
toutes les jours c'est quoi c'est 300
calories même pas là
ma mère est venue me voir puis les
téléphones existaient dans ce club
j'avais un flip phone puis mon ordi il
pleut ma mère m'a dit je pense que c'est
demander qu'est-ce que je peux y enlever
pour que ça se réveille et puis
peut-être qu'elle fasse un mot enfin qui
a dit regarde je sais pas qu'est-ce que
tu fais
mais peu importe ce que tu fais si
t'arrête pas je vais t'enlever toutes
tes affaires parce que là faut que tu
changes puis je suis comme portable
j'ai réussi à maigrir enfin si je me
fais plus écorer le monde me dit que je
suis belle blablabla revenait pas et
puis elle a voyant mini tu es à essayer
le Gym puis on avait un gym comme à
trois rides chez nous la caméra acheter
un abonnement au gym puis depuis ce
temps-là j'ai arrêté de consommer puis
je me suis entraîné encore jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est ça tout le temps était
un peu mon échappatoire quand je suis si
je me sentais pas bien j'allais au gym
tout le temps
qui a fonctionné
ma vie plusieurs fois je pense que c'est
pas mais c'est fou de mettons quand on
sait le reste de l'histoire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais donc cette intervention
là parce que ok non là un problème là
hop on ramène
plat après ça les premières vont
recommencer mais dans le fond j'ai eu
quand même un mode de vie simple
relativement longtemps puis j'avais été
à l'école pour faire une formation en
vente et conseils puis j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un à ce moment-là puis c'est
devenu mon copain pendant 2 ans mais
c'était une relation un peu malsaine des
deux côtés dans le sens que lui je pense
qu'il y avait des blessures de de son
passé que il projetait sur moi puis moi
j'avais une grosse insécurité envers
moi-même puis en général enfin je pense
qu'on se fidèle un peu là dessus puis
mettons lui m'empêcha de sortir de voir
mes amis je pouvais pas aller au bord et
fallait que je travaille puis je
revienne chez nous direct mais
c'était vraiment vraiment malsain puis
quand j'ai finalement sorti de cette
relation là on dirait que j'avais
tellement été en cabanais pendant deux
ans que là c'est comme si tu laisses un
oiseau en liberté qui a été dans une
cage pas toute sa vie mais pendant un
bon bout de temps enfin j'ai commencé à
ressortir c'est là que j'ai fait des
rencontres puis pas nécessairement des
rencontres que j'aurais dû faire ou que
j'aurais fait si j'avais pas commencé à
sortir dans les bars puis
sabres d'alcool je me rendais compte que
quand je buvais d'alcool j'avais
beaucoup de bobos qui est arrivé des
derniers 5 ans que j'ai jamais même
effleurer le sujet personne
dans cette situation là de comme de de
c'est quoi c'est quoi mon cœur cherche
d'inhibition puis j'avais l'impression
que ça faisait beaucoup d'anxiété je
savais pas non plus quand je suis revenu
puis je commençais à faire une
dépression je le savais pas non plus pas
j'ai jamais été dépressive vraiment à
part peut-être en prison là puis je
trouvais que ça normal à quelque part
mais puis je trouvais que quand je
consommais d'alcool mais je me sentais
mieux ça que là mettons ma fête a duré
peut-être une semaine parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de gens qu'on qu'on
voulait célébrer ensemble mais après
cette semaine là j'habitais chez ma mère
dans le temps puis je buvais à toutes
les jours pour aucune raison mettons
était 10h30 le matin je me disais bah
c'est un gars qui part dans le monde je
m'ouvrais un white club
aucune raison de voir l'alcool qui est
bien
ça a duré pendant un bout de temps
puis un moment donné j'ai juste craqué
chez ma mère puis des fois je faisais de
la bouffe je partais à pleurer puis je
savais pas pourquoi pas on est malade
elle m'a pris puis à 10 minutes ça
serait pas normal que tu pleures pas
après c'est normal que tu reprennes
n'existence normale et puis moi je te
laisse faire je me suis dit à votre
réveiller puis elle va me dire le faut
faire de quoi le parce que ça marche pas
ce que je fais dans le déni complètement
je sais que ça l'inquiétait mais elle a
appris aussi au travers des années que
plus qu'à m'empêche plus ça va être payé
tu veux sortir vas-y je sortais
sérieusement quatre fois par semaine
encore genre j'ai comme recommencer mon
patin
sans côtoyer des gens que je devrais pas
évidemment j'ai fait des super belles
rencontres malgré mon mon buvage alcool
mais mais je me suis réveillé une
journée puis j'ai dit ça marche pas
lorsque je fais je m'entraînais plus
j'avais pris du poids
c'est en prison j'ai j'ai eu 5 ans mais
tombe pas rien faire mais j'ai pris 5
ans là ou ben quatre ans le 1er année je
m'entraînais pas puis je me suis
entraîné à toutes les jours pendant 4
ans avec je suis revenu puis en plus la
dernière que j'avais fait c'était des
camions lourds enfin que c'était une job
de golf série des gars qui faisait ça
anciennement puis ça a été transfert aux
femmes enfin que j'étais vraiment hachée
puis là j'avais tout perdu ça puis j'ai
buvait puis je mangeais mal puis j'étais
comme moi qu'est-ce que je fais tu sais
je pensais jamais moi je pensais revenir
puis tout allait être à 1 si je me dis
j'ai fait 50 prisons que c'est qu'il
peut bien aller mal dans ma vie quand je
retourne chez nous c'est que ça a été
vraiment Rohff de me réveiller puis dire
ouais là faut que je fasse la thérapie
moi je pensais que c'était juste le
monde malade qui voyait les psychologues
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y a plein
de monde qui sentent super bien à tous
les jours puis qu'il voit quand même un
psychologue une fois par mois juste pour
comme vent juste pour sortir un peu de
mes chantiers je pense la communication
c'est une grosse une grosse chose que
j'ai appris à faire avec le temps aussi
là la question de pH qui était une
réalité dépendante si mettons si c'est
pas à l'alcool ou à la drogue ça se peut
de sucre ça soit
la tension
c'est intéressant de
dans ce temps-là il y avait quelque
chose qui t'a attiré là-dedans puis
justement tu parlais d'un Instagram
les jeunes ou c'est pas la réalité qui
miroitait vraiment la preuve que c'est
vrai que c'est les années d'influence
c'est vrai puis on
on est vraiment on est rendu bon mais je
pense que les en 2016 aussi c'est un peu
comme ça mais on est rendu bon pour
miroiter une vie qui n'est pas la note
puis souvent je regarde et Instagram je
me dis c'est impossible que ça soit sur
ta vie c'est pas la réalité c'est pas
parce que en fait du parachute à tous
les jours ou tu sais c'est tout est
parfait parfait parfait parfait je me
dis hey je peux pas croire qu'il y a du
monde puis c'est correct le domaine des
belles images puis tout à l'heure
heureuse mais à quelque part il faut que
tu ailles un petit graine de réalité
dans ton Instagram pour que le monde
puisse relect avec toi on dirait que
tout le monde voit on veut tout le temps
reproduire ce qu'on voit tout le temps
si ton Instagram tu le regardes 67
heures par jour puis que tout ce que tu
regardes c'est des ongles parfaits des
cheveux parfaits makeup parfait les
linges c'est sûr tu vas rechercher ça à
quelque part je pense que c'est
important de se détacher justement
d'Instagram c'est moi en fin de semaine
je veux m'en aller parce que j'ai aussi
mais là c'est sûr que je réponds il y a
beaucoup de monde qui m'ont écrit pour
être super gentil puis j'essaie de
répondre à tout le monde mais en général
mes amis me reprochent que je leur écris
jamais ou je les appelle jamais puis je
leur dis ouais mais la minute que je
peux lâcher mon téléphone je l'ai acheté
parce que je sais à quel point que c'est
toxique puis j'aimerais ça que que j'ai
regardé un étude récemment ça disait
il y a une étude qui était faite sur des
hommes et des femmes ça disait est-ce
que tu aimerais mieux passer 15 minutes
avec toi-même sans distraction pas de
téléphone TV rien juste toi tout seul
dans une salle pendant 15 minutes ou te
donner un choc électrique puis 30% des
hommes ont choisi choc électrique 60%
donc 30 % des femmes ont choisi ça
électrique puis 60% des hommes ont
choisi choc électrique je me disais et
ça ça veut dire que le monde a peur
d'être seul avec eux-mêmes parce qu'il y
a tellement de choses que tu veux pas
t'avouer à toi-même 60 % des hommes
quand même ça c'est beaucoup là comment
que les hommes ont des avec nos émotions
moi j'ai eu je veux pas dire j'ai eu 5
ans pour m'asseoir avec moi-même parce
que
j'avais quand même
mais reste que exemple les deux
premières semaines quand j'étais
incarcéré j'avais pas de télévision pas
de téléphone tu étais enfermé pendant 16
heures par jour dans ta cellule puis
c'est une fille que je connais pas qui
est avec moi puis je parle à moitié
anglais j'étais assise mon lit à
longueur de la journée à rien faire
parce que tu es comme comme je dis on
est né avec un téléphone des mains ou
une distraction c'est à tout bout de
champ mais moi c'est le meilleur conseil
que je peux donner du monde c'est des
plugs comme du monde pendant cette
semaine puis tu me diras si tu as pas
changé quand tu reviens
évidemment je compare vraiment beaucoup
mais loin de moi je veux rien comparé
parce que la comparaison existe pas là
mais le plus proche que j'ai passé
justement de pas avoir de distraction
c'était
occupation puis c'est le plus proche que
j'ai passé de la prison
mais je veux dire tu es quand même
contrôlé à 100%
mais j'ai quand même été trois mois sans
mon cellulaire puis avec aucune
possibilité à part parler tout le temps
au même monde parce que tu parles tout
le temps aux personnes autour de toi
puis
pour moi imaginer cinq ans en prison
c'est comme ça
pour moi c'est impossible c'est même pas
je sais même pas capable d'imaginer que
ça peut être parce que après trois mois
des fois je prenais ma tête puis je me
colle ça à tête dans mon matelas parce
que j'avais rien à faire c'est puis tu
es tout seul avec toi-même puis c'est là
que genre des fois je me mettais à
pleurer dans mon lit pour qu'une raison
et puis toutes les gars avec qui j'en
parlais avaient des breakdown comme ça
genre de gros breakdance j'imagine que
ça arrive mais c'est correct tu
comprends quand on quand ta tête le te
mets dans un mode breakdown c'est parce
que tu as quelque chose à breakdown puis
analyser à quelque part parce que tu
pourras pas pour rien en réalité enfin
si tu as un signal comme ça le monde
souvent ont tendance à faire
complètement le contraire est un signal
il y a quelque chose qui va pas mais tu
es comment ça va être correct ça va
passer c'est important de prendre
conscience de quitter parce que ça là un
coup que tu te guéri ou que tu analyser
c'est quoi puis tu trouves une solution
mais ça va changer quelque chose après
ça pour le reste de ta vie probablement
parce que tu vas savoir ben ça faut pas
que j'aille là pas je me sentais comme
ça pour comprendre quelque chose faut
que tu as véhicule contraire puis moi je
dis puis je peux pas personne de faire
la prison mais je dis tout le temps il
faudrait que tout le monde fasse une
semaine pas en prison mais une semaine
avec aucun privilège aucun rien rien une
semaine complète assez dans une pièce
à réfléchir il y en a qui vont virer
fous mais il y en a aussi qui vont c'est
que tu vas faire une rétrospection de la
mort puis moi puis j'avais le choix de
virer folles pour les proches une coupe
de fois là je me disais jamais je vois
jamais je jouais capable de faire ça
puis je savais pas en plus combien de
temps je m'en allais
puis en plus blanc mais tout le monde
sauf moi c'est fac un moment donné j'ai
eu ça aussi j'ai un switch qui s'est
fait je me suis dit à écoute bien il y a
personne qui était obligé à faire ça il
y a personne qui t'a torture
complètement dit oui pour des raisons
égoïstes ben assume c'est puis je voyais
d'autres filles qui me disaient arrête
de broyer toi choisi de faire ça
c'est ça je trouve ça absolument je sais
même pas c'est quoi l'adjectif que
j'utiliserai pour décrire comme comment
je trouve ça mais
l'idée d'aller en prison maintenant je
te parle j'écoutais le podcast avec
Étienne que tu as fait aussi le boulet
puis il disait un peu la même chose mais
comme je te parle puis je n'ai pas
l'impression de parler à une
criminels
c'est une longue peine 5 ans c'est pas
genre un 24 heures dans une station de
police là c'est 5 fois 15 années à
l'international puis
des fois je me pose le commentaire quand
je suis dans ma vie je me dis genre au
final tout le monde est genre
tout le monde
de ce ramasser en prison
ça m'est déjà arrivé de prendre mon char
au-dessus de la limite c'est sûr ça
m'est déjà arrivé puis quand j'y repense
plus je le fais plus maintenant je fais
vraiment attention mais quand je repars
je me dis je suis à ça de frapper
quelqu'un puis d'être en prison pour 10
ans
on dirait que cette pensée là fait
capoter puis je t'entendais justement
quand tu parlais de du moment où est-ce
que vous êtes descendu du bateau mettons
que la police était là avec les chiens
en Australie
moi il y a un policier qui met ses
gyrophares en arrière de moi j'ai les
jambes j'ai envie de me chier dessus
maintenant
j'imagine que moi
il y a des policiers qui sont avec des
chiens le pire feeling au monde entier
sûrement mais il y a quand même une
différence parce que
si exemple la police t'arrête pour X
raisons tu es conscients qui a peut-être
que tu voulais un petit peu trop vite
mais tu dis tout le temps ouais on va
peut-être l'échapper c'est moi je me
disais il y avait mince chance
c'était pas une option c'était une
option surtout parce que ça je le
raconte aussi le mais quand on est
arrivé au Canada on s'était fait poser
des questions parce que dans le fond le
bateau il est parti de Londres puis on
est revenu en Nouvelle-Écosse et puis on
s'est fait poser des questions par les
douaniers puis demander comme qui qui a
payé votre croisière pendant tout le
long je me dis oh c'est sûr c'est sûr
on n'a pas été cher
j'ai comme eu l'impression que peut-être
les personnes qui vous a dit genre
en fait j'ai pas vraiment posé de
questions à travers toute
parce que j'ai j'avais 22 ans puis je
passais à mon petit nombril
le moins possible puis je pensais plus à
mes photos que j'allais mettre sur
Instagram puis à quel point que la mode
allait manger puis me donner la tension
que je sais pas pourquoi je cherchais
autant que peut-être si je m'étais posé
question dans ma jeunesse si j'avais
cherché de l'aide à me comprendre
pourquoi je me mets autant pas puis
pourquoi chanter que ça les autres
qu'elle allait me donner la table dans
le dos que j'avais besoin parce que
réellement
tu pourras jamais être à 100% satisfait
de ce que tu fais si tu es pas satisfait
toi-même tu sais ta famille au complet
pourrait durer c'est vraiment hâte que
tu fasses un podcast mais toi tu viens
reculons à toutes les jours ça
t'apportera jamais à 100% ce que tu as
besoin je pense que les jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est un peu ça
puis c'est de l'eau vient de se demander
sincèrement c'est quoi qu'on veut dans
la vie tu sais puis les jeunes ont été
tellement puis encore moi aujourd'hui je
peux parfaite je veux dire je me suis
tout le temps distraite par plein
d'affaires mais
on
laisse trop les jeunes aller piquer si
j'appelle ça du quaieling mais genre
exemple que toi tu commences à
travailler chez Best bye tu mettes dans
le temps de nos parents là si ton père
avait une job puis que il y a le dire à
son père et pas
je me pose pas trop chaud
tu quitte ta job quand tu étais jeune
c'est comme ça que nos parents sont
devenus résilients puis avec des
carrières puis à cette heure croyait
Queen pour moi c'est comme tu vas dire à
ta mère en main là j'ai besoin de mes
boss sont pas faim mon amour mais c'est
pas grave change puis va voir ailleurs
non faut qu'on conditionne nos enfants
que ça sera pas toujours facile qu'on
prend il y en aura pas de facile dans la
vie puis au pire tu vas te planter dans
ta job mais ça va t'apprendre que ça
c'était pas fait pour toi puis tu vas
vraiment te poser ok mais là tout ça
j'aimais pas ça enfin que c'est quoi
d'autre que je peux faire assez on est
tellement rendu doux est-ce que tu
penses que toi c'était
là juste le choix de la voix facile
d'accéder à cette espèce de cette espèce
de monde là que tu voulais par une voix
facile
parce que je travaille tellement là
de la peau dans notre ligne
une voix facile de voyager de voyager
t'as pas besoin de travailler fort pour
faire ça tu en voilà que j'ai besoin de
prendre un risque
de faire là j'ai accès à ça sans tout ce
que ça prendrait pour faire ça
mais en même temps à quel point si je me
dis à quel point je t'apprête de prendre
des risques c'est ça qui est stupide
la grande ça vaut vraiment à peine de
faire ce que tu t'en vas faire là ou
c'était juste comme pierre puis je sais
pas un excuse mais c'est arrivé dernière
minute la deuxième fois dans le fond
qu'on me l'a proposé enfin je parte deux
semaines après faire
j'étais comme aller m'assurer que
j'allais pouvoir avoir ma job en
revenant puis là j'étais comme acquis
mais là ça veut dire que je vais
peut-être pouvoir aider telle telle
personne financièrement puis moi aussi
je vais pouvoir faire ce que je veux
faire puis on dirait que ça a tellement
été vite dans ma tête je souhaite comme
ok on y va let's go genre c'est une
chance là il y a un ordre des fois dans
ma vie
[Musique]
si qu'est-ce que je regarde après ma
deuxième fois
que tu saches un peu filtré
avec Étienne aussi je t'ai comme je
reviens pas que j'ai vu ça un peu comme
ça
c'est le piercing de la ville
j'encourage zéro
je dis tout le temps les pires erreurs
que tu as fait dans ta vie ça va être
les meilleurs ressorts tu auras pas
appris reste que j'encourage pas
personne à faire rien de criminel puis
d'apprendre quelque chose de tout mais
tu aurais appris quelque chose d'autre
pour rien dans le sens que on a quand
même
je t'ai coupé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le but de la leçon mais en même temps je
pense que la raison pourquoi ça est
arrivé à moi il y avait une raison X
puis ça le fait en sorte que j'en suis
sorti relativement scène d'esprit puis
que je suis capable d'être assis à
plusieurs endroits puis de parler de
cette histoire là qui est ma vie
pour essayer de le donner une méchante
leçon à d'autres et puis souvent les
commentaires que je lis en ligne c'est
comment je comprends pas qu'on encourage
les criminels là-dedans à la communion
écrivent les médias la supportent puis
je dis c'est l'avantage je me dis écoute
peut-être que moi je mérite pas d'être
pas dépassé à TV là moi je mérite pas de
passer à TV parce que j'ai commis un
crime c'était pas réfléchi mais
l'histoire puis la leçon par exemple ça
ça a le droit de passer à PV parce qu'il
faut que les gens s'en rappellent
personne c'est comme on encourage les
criminels à se rétablir puis là on va
les encourager dans leur projet que je
me dis je pense pas que c'est ça la
leçon à retenir je pense que la
ressortonner c'est que normalement il y
a beaucoup en fait la le plus gros
pourcentage de criminels qui retourne en
prison c'est ceux qui ont pas eu de
soutien et de support en sortant parce
que la communauté puis la société ne
veut pas aider les criminels puis il y a
pas de programme pour les criminels
quand ils sort comme bon ben salut puis
votre trouver une job avec un dossier
ici impossible moi je chante ça j'en ai
pas de dossier j'en ai juste en
Australie Teng God parce que même que
j'ai même si j'ai pas de dossier je suis
quand même pénalisé dans des affaires
ici c'est mon mon assurance auto a
augmenté puis j'ai dû changer d'assureur
je n'aimerais pas qui là mais la fille
m'a dit la fille m'a dit dans le fond la
gérante de cette compagnie d'assurance
auto là on dit à la conseillère qui
faisait ma demande de de prime
d'assurance parce que je voulais
m'acheter un auto 2015
par mois
j'ai rappelé j'ai dit cassé 4000 pièces
par année tu vois je comprends pas c'est
c'est la supervisoire qui a dit ça je
vous écoute on retourne à ta superviseur
puis une Mandy que ce qui fait en sorte
que ça me coûte 4000 parce que j'ai
jamais eu de réclamation d'assurance
j'ai jamais eu un arrêt de paiement puis
c'est en 2015 je conduis pas Maserati
puis à me rappeler puis c'était écrit t
par message puis a dit à moi juste
répondu tu as juste à taper son nom sur
Google
parce que
ça c'est arrivé c'est même pas parce que
j'ai un dossier criminel puis faire un
œuf en même temps tout le monde a son
opinion puis c'est correct d'avoir un
opinion négatif parce que rien possible
parce que j'ai fait mais reste que faut
que le monde comprenne que osto tu fais
une connerie peut-être ou grande que tu
as un dossier criminel tu vas racheter
toute ta vie après ouais c'est ça pitié
les gens peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
avoir leur opinion mais tu sais
le modèle de la société dans laquelle on
vit c'est on croit que les gens peuvent
être réhabiliter après avoir
fait leur peine sinon on va juste mettre
le monde tout le temps en prison à vie
puis genre ça va ça va être réglé ça va
être fini mais c'est pas ça c'est moi je
suis tout à fait normal que tu puisses
sortir après ça puis peut-être ton
expérience puis venir ici puis faire
tout ce que tu veux j'ai rencontré gros
des gens aussi en prison c'est pas
des
erreurs une première fois puis qui tu en
les Rihanna tu dis c'est qu'il y a pas
plus jamais ça tu es à le compris autant
que moi là que ça c'était juste une
décision spontanée stupide puis qu'on a
jamais évalué les conséquences que ça
pouvait avoir mais en même temps
je trouve que c'est un peu injuste dans
le sens de pas vouloir qu'il y a une
réhabilitation pour les criminels et moi
je me fais boucher parce que j'écris un
livre qui va peut-être aider d'autres
filles ou garçons a pour faire ce que
j'ai fait c'est pourquoi je peux pas
pourquoi j'ai pas le droit de partager
ça je comprends pas ça pourrait être ta
fille ou ton gars qui va lire mon livre
puis ça va aussi justement ton histoire
est vraiment frappante là-dessus c'est
que c'est pas juste le monde qui ont des
familles complètement dysfonctionnelles
complètement foule difficile qui qui
font des
erreurs qui s'embrassent en prison je
veux dire c'est arrivé à toi ça peut
arriver
puis je pense que t'en parlais aussi
avec Étienne tu sais on aimerait ça
penser que tiens il disait j'aimerais
pas penser que mon dealers c'est un
instigateur
c'était vraiment un good guy et puis
c'est amener une descente qui fait chier
qui arrive chez eux puis que les gars
c'est un manteau mais c'est pas une
mauvaise personne
peu tant que la drogue qui va se
consommer
en contact avec ces gens-là ou avec tes
anciennes fréquentations non je peux
rentrer en contact avec les gens qui ont
été impliqués dans dans tout ça mais oui
j'ai reparlé à des anciennes amis qui
étaient mes entreprises fréquentations
puis je le sais j'ai pas arrêté de me
tenir avec eux parce que c'est des
mauvaises personnes c'est juste que on
n'est pas c'est mes principes puis où
est-ce que je veux m'en aller dans vie
puis où est-ce que elle elles sont dans
la vie ça me rejoint pas puis je veux
pas être la personne qui va dire à tous
les jours pourquoi tu fais ça c'est pas
le fun de se sentait jugé puis je suis
vraiment une personne directe d'envie
puis je sais que je serais pas capable
de m'empêcher de de pas de juger mais
dire faisons d'autres choses aussi tu es
intelligent des fois c'est pas tout le
monde qui veut l'entendre puis tu as pas
un choix de lui puis ça ça te regarde
puis moi je respecte
tout ce que les jardins de travail que
ce soit
moins bien côté dans société que qui est
un médecin par exemple mais ça ça
regarde eux mais est-ce que moi je veux
m'associer avec ça puis est-ce que moi
je trouve que j'ai des points en commun
c'est différent c'est là
maintenant puis qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire
fréquentation de ton entourage
primordial dans le sens que ça ça finit
par
devenir la personne que tu vas devenir
ou que tu es présentement
avec toute la je veux dire
si tu tiens avec des entrepreneurs
éventuellement tu as peut-être vouloir
faire quelque chose qui va d'aligner va
être un entrepreneur puis avoir ton
propre projet à toi si tu tiens avec des
gens qui sortent à toutes les fin de
semaine puis qui dépensent toutes leurs
paies puis que lundi vous je suis allé
tout dans votre groupe facebook et vous
avez donc plus d'argent mais c'est ça
c'est vers là tu t'en vas tout ton
entourage si ça va te représenter c'est
cette bulle enfin c'est important de
faire attention à ça aussi de d'être
certain à 100%, ça se peut que tu fasses
des rencontres mais aussi tout un doute
poses une question pourquoi tu as un
doute c'est continue pas de de nourrir
ça c'est faut que tu saches absolument
avec qui tu tiens puis moi j'ai
peut-être pas fait cette étape là quand
j'étais plus jeune puis ça m'a amené ou
est-ce que ça m'a amené c'était quoi ton
niveau de stress avant d'embarquer sur
ce bateau là mettons là mais
moi moi je pense parce que je pense
j'arrêtais baigne trop terrifié pour ça
envisager
je vais prendre j'ai déjà essayé de
rentrer
des de l'extasie dans un festival mais
bon
tout le monde en a le t-shirt tout le
monde autour de moi un œuf tout le monde
c'est normal puis même je t'adore je
peux pas je peux pas je peux pas passer
le gars qui veut juste faire
je peux pas rentrer maintenant
faut qu'on comprenne ça avant l'autre
jour même à faire
des petites
pilule de moche les métaux
arrive juste au truc
ok
festival versus
oui c'est sûr qu'un stress qui est là
c'est comme j'ai dit souvent je peux je
pouvais pas
je peux pas enjoy le voyage à 100% parce
que tu sais que quelque chose qui se
passe en arrière de tout ça ça oui
j'avais un stress pas mal tout le long
mais en même temps initialement
l'implication était pas très grande
c'était stressant mais pas tard mais
mettons après le Canada quand on s'est
fait poser des questions moi qui
regardait beaucoup d'émission sur les
douanes puis tout ça je me dis c'est
certain
certains qui vont regarder toutes sortes
Nouvelle Écosse ok au Canada
on a mis de l'argent de côté pendant
longtemps c'était quoi notre job c'est
clairment avec le salaire qu'on faisait
il fallait qu'on économise pendant 10
ans j'avais 22 ans ça fait déjà commencé
à économiser à 12 ans pour un voyage
ça aurait pu pied encore aujourd'hui je
sais pas qu'est-ce que vous faites en
sorte que ça déclenché tout
l'investigation là c'est ça va pas mal
rester dans des nuages le reste de ma
vie probablement mais peut-être qu'elle
fait que je l'avais autant aussi exposée
vous vous êtes un peu exposé vous-même
dans un sens là sur les réseaux sociaux
plus qu'on s'expose moins qu'on en a un
coupable
plus qu'on enlève dans la classe que
quelqu'un le coupable
le monde me dira tu as fait le livre
pour la popularité ou l'argent puis je
leur dis si tu savais ce que j'ai dit
sur moi-même dans ce livre sérieusement
tu sais j'ai je le fais pas
mon Dieu je serai jamais le mettre en
mot mais il y a trop de choses dans
lesquelles j'ai tellement honte d'avoir
que autant de gens qui savent ça sur moi
incluant mes grands-parents mon père
c'est mon père quand il finir mon livre
on s'appelait puis j'en tremblais là
puis mon père il sentait mal aussi
je peux pas en tout comme moi
personnellement je me serais jamais
remis je me serais jamais mis aussi tout
nu mettons un bon québécois là pour de
l'argent et puis un livre puis je vois
juste pas le point là-dedans de mettre
un côté monétaire et puis pour être
famous ben moi je trouve pas que je suis
plus fameux aujourd'hui dans le sens que
c'est une fameuse en anglais le Comité
populaire pour les mauvaises raisons
c'est fait que je le vois pas d'un coup
c'est pas positif pour moi la raison
pour que les gens me connaissent pas que
non ça a pas
ça a l'air même pas rapport avec ça
c'est c'est sincèrement parce que puis
moi j'ai des petites soeurs qui l'ont vu
ils n'ont pas eu facile aux autres quand
je me suis fait arrêter ils m'ont tout
en vue un peu comme la grandeur puis eux
autres aussi il y a eu vraiment beaucoup
de problèmes dans leur côté puis je me
suis dit ça aurait tellement pu être
heureux parce que ils ont pris un peu un
chemin
rocky road là après ça que
peuvent lire mon livre je sais que son
règne de lire je sais que ça va leur
apprendre de quoi puisqu'ils vont
peut-être changer de parcotter enfin que
tu t'es complètement
tu t'es fait de
cette problème là que tu avais avec leur
garde des autres finalement
ça c'est à réfléchir 50 à cellules ou
c'est les conseils
je veux dire piété c'est pas pour pas
pour être négatif envers le look de
personne mais c'est les gens qui ont
fait ils ont accompli les plus grandes
choses dans vie je vais nommer Steve
Jobs puis toutes les plus grands
Einstein là c'est pas des gens qui
étaient top models chez Vogue on
s'entend
pas
tu peux pas tu peux pas à moins que tu
sois modèle là on s'entend si tu as des
traits de fou tu peux mettre tu peux
vous rendre tout ça euh d'une belle
façon monnayable dans le sens que puis
il y a plein de de modèles qu'il y a une
autre janeux à l'encourage beaucoup tout
ce qui sentait mentale les problèmes de
justement les filles qui ont des des
problèmes d'anorexie tout de suite c'est
elle à l'utilise sa beauté parce que les
jeunes vont la regarder mais elle
utilise une belle façon on se compare
pas Kendall en disant
elle a promouvoir qui c'est important de
de d'avoir une bonne estime de soi puis
à l'encourage plein de de de de gens qui
ont des voyants je pense tout le temps
en anglais pour que je traduis dans ma
tête là les organismes qui encourage
tout ça facture il y a toujours moyen
mais je pense pas que de se dire qu'il
faut être belle pour réussir dans la vie
c'est avec ça que tu vas aller loin ça
peut être un atout mais en même temps
c'est ton cerveau qui va qui va
t'avancer
moi je me rappelle quand que
la première c'était genre
astique
c'est comme live change
moi j'avais pas nécessairement de
négatif par rapport à ça mon deuxième ma
deuxième pensée c'était
parce que le des artistes qui étaient
sortis c'était comme c'était des mots
clés puis premièrement qui s'était mal
repris aussi l'histoire si c'était comme
deux influenceuses parties
puis genre
partie avec un sugar daddy qui a payé un
voyage pour la politique c'est tellement
pas pour aller prendre des photos de
voyage
c'est le comble de l'espèce de build up
de ce qu'Instagram devenait je me disais
genre là on approche à quelque chose où
est-ce que le boum puis comment c'était
raconté c'était deux filles qui
voulaient prendre des photos de voyage
prennent cette décision là je me
rappelle m'a dit on est rendu au bout de
ce que Instagram peut amener puis de ce
que genre les réseaux sociaux peuvent
amener comme comme désir de
de flasher puis de vivre une vie qui est
pas vraiment qui est pas vraiment
puis
mais après ça je t'entendais avec
Étienne dire c'était pas ça pendant tout
c'est l'histoire c'était pas ça c'était
quoi mettons les plus après ça j'imagine
que tu as pas vu nécessairement les
nouvelles mais
parler mais c'était quoi qui était le
plus déformé de ce soir-là de ce qu'on
disait mais on n'a jamais été pour une
star ni escort sexuel enfin que déjà là
on partait déjà de loin
ils ont pris des images puis des
commentaires à gauche à droite puis on
fait un formé un histoire avec sauté au
début j'étais fâché de tout ça parce que
je me disais à réputation blabla puis
après ça je me suis dit c'est quoi
ça va peut-être être une belle leçon
justement pour d'autres gens qui
s'embarquent dans des réelles histoires
comme ça qui s'en vont vers cette
cheminée
puis qui vont se rendre compte
tabarouette c'est plus dangereux que je
pensais tu sais puis
j'ai connu le monde escortexuel parce
que j'avais j'ai des amis ou
connaissances qui faisaient ça dans le
temps enfin que je sais c'est quoi puis
je sais où est-ce que ça peut t'amener
puis ça a pas toujours été beau on a
envie de mes amis puis ça a été même
dangereux quelquefois
je me dis bon c'est pas bon pour moi
dans le sens que si je me disais à ma
famille Lisa puis il doit être dévasté
là c'est vraiment pas le fun pour un
jour de lire ça mais aujourd'hui je le
vois vraiment comme
peut-être que j'ai l'air une cruche ok
pour avoir fait ce que j'ai fait mais en
même temps il y a peut-être d'autres
filles qui vont me regarder puis ça va
les faire réfléchir
qui est important là-dedans
il y a des décisions personnelles de ça
qui est une erreur de jugement
on se voit comme
le produit de notre environnement puis
de la société mais sans dit long aussi
ce qui te poussait à dire à faire ça
sans dit long aussi sur les climats puis
la société dans laquelle on vit
maintenant
je veux dire le monde il me lance des
commentaires comme que j'ai expliqué
puis ils sont mais sont tellement fermés
d'esprit puis c'est aux autres ils
voient que j'ai écrit un livre là il y a
même pas pris probablement la peine de
lire c'est quoi que le livre à propos
c'est à propos de quoi il y a juste dit
comme elle a créé pour l'argent je
trouve que il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont très fermés d'esprit
puis malheureusement des gens qui font
des commentaires comme ça souvent puis
je sais pas psychologue mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est des gens qui qui
reflètent un peu ce que eux vivent dans
leur vie dans le sens que si tu
es fâché dans ta vie puis tu es pas
heureux mais tu vas
tu vas refléter ça sur d'autres gens
puis c'est un autre histoire que j'ai
entendu de gars il racontait que
il était censé les jouer au tennis avec
des amis puis tu es arrivé une
demi-heure en retard parce que il était
parti à l'heure puis après ça il est
arrêté d'acheter un café pour avoir une
demi-heure en retard puis il sentait
vraiment mal ses amis puis tu es arrivé
au comptoir du Gym pour s'inscrire pour
le tennis mais il était pressé et puis
la fille a branlait parce qu'elle
faisait d'autres choses puis il disait
j'avais juste goûté quand même comme ah
ouais mais dit pourquoi je projetterais
ma frustration sourire quand c'est de ma
faute que je t'ai en retard pourquoi
elle la mangerait de la merde je me dis
moi j'essaie de faire de quoi pour aider
les autres parce que ça leur en général
si tu regardes le livre puis dans
d'autres la pochette c'est pas mal
évident que je vois pas mais je me porte
au contraire je me mets vraiment pas en
valeur parce que je veux qu'il y a du
monde qui fasse comme je suis vraiment
pas loin que de ce que tu as fait là
était à 22 ans si vous saviez le nombre
de filles qui m'ont écrit depuis la
sortie du livre on dit tu as vraiment
réveillé quelque chose en moi puis j'ai
broyé parce que je me suis rendu compte
que je m'en allais peut-être ou est-ce
que tu te puis même pas par rapport à la
drogue juste en général comme il me
disait j'accorde vraiment trop
d'importance à moins Instagram puis je
viens de me rendre compte que je suis
malheureuse à cause de ça c'est moi
j'étais là merci mon Dieu c'est juste ça
que je veux que on arrête de se mettre
au temps de pression sur être belle
peut-être parfaite puis tu sais le
succès c'est variable à tout le monde là
je dis vous êtes pas médecin ou je sais
pas ce que vous avez étudié d'envie mais
aujourd'hui vous faites des podcasts
c'est super hot là mais il y en a
peut-être qui va vous regarder et puis
vous dire que c'est pas réussir dans la
vie faire des podcasts ben trop facile
moi mais pour toi peut-être c'est ça la
réussite que tu réussis à avoir
l'information de de des gens super le
fun à parler que puis au bout de la
ligne là tu vas peut-être savoir pas mal
plus d'affaires d'envie que quelqu'un
qui qui est médecin me tombe dans des
seins différentes mais ça reste que
toutes les connaissances dans plein
d'affaires avec le succès faut pas
écouter ou voir ou regarder ce que la
société veut qu'on soit du succès pierre
un code qui disait ça en anglais là mais
ça disait comme
c'est comme si c'est la société qui
parle ça disait soit toi-même trois
petits points non pas comme ça
toi-même mais le toi-même que nous on
veut que tu souhaites il faut vraiment
se détacher de ça je trouve c'est
vraiment important de se détacher de ça
et puis moi encore aujourd'hui je sais
pas oui je sais qu'est-ce que je veux
faire comme carrière mais là avec le
livre je comme
il faut que j'aille une carrière
professionnelle mais j'aimerais vraiment
ça faire des conférences avec les jeunes
puis aller voir des jeunes à DPJ puis
descendre jeunesse puis des écoles
secondaires plaisirs puisque moi mais je
peux vraiment faire une carrière là
dessus je veux tout garder les deux
puis après ça je me dis hey c'est ça que
je veux faire je vais juste le faire
après parce que les autres vont dire
la seconde que tu décides
d'exposer publiquement
va venir avec ça des commentaires de
marbre
même pas la critique la critique c'est
une chose si tu fais un livre tu
t'exposes à critique peu importe le mais
si tu fais si tu prends une position
publique tu deviens juste public peu
importe de quelle façon tu t'exposes à
des commentaires de merde ça vient
automatiquement je connais personne qui
a une tribune ou qui a
un des gens qui le suivent ou tu sais
une personnalité publique qui a pas de
commentaire de merde ça n'existe pas
fait c'est sûr que celui-là toi tu viens
de sortir ton livre les premiers
commentaires c'est les piles les
premiers commentaires de merde c'est
ceux qui font le plus mal parce que tu
es pas prête encore à avoir des
commentaires de même c'est probablement
pas des premiers commentaires de merde
peut-être que les autres les œufs
polluent maintenant
en Allemagne c'est pas je lis pas les
commentaires c'est les messages qui me
sont envoyés directement
c'est une des raisons c'est que j'ai
parlé avec les idiots quand j'ai fait un
tournage là il y a pas longtemps
c'était tellement une personne douce
puis gentille puis comme mais tu vois
qu'elle a du véhicule dans tes yeux si
on peut en parler puis comment tu
trouves ça c'est le public que c'est toi
maintenant tu pourrais être mère Teresa
puis il y a quelqu'un qui va toujours
avoir de quoi dire malheureusement ces
problèmes des personnes qui sont pas
heureux dans leur vie puis qui ont
jamais fait de progrès qui sont restés à
même place c'est vrai la seule affaire
qui va t'apporter du bonheur dans la vie
je pense c'est le secret pour être
heureux d'envie c'est de faire du
progrès la minute que tu progresse dans
quelque chose que tu vois un un progrès
tu es content bonheur chercher du
progrès un peu partout tu sais
peu importe où dans ta relation au
travail au gym avec tes enfants et
n'importe quoi je pense que c'est ça le
secrété ça que oui ça a été Rohff de
prendre des commentaires négatifs mais
ce qui m'a choque est plus c'est la à
quel point c'était méchant puis où
est-ce qu'elle monte son prête à la
réalité puis non vraiment puis le monde
savent pas c'est peut-être que j'ai
l'air de la fille qui est donc en
contrôle des entreprises et tout le
monde me donnait des bons commentaires
puis ils me disent que je m'exprime bien
et puis moi j'ai jamais fait d'entrevue
fait que je savais pas comment ça allait
aller honnêtement
chez nous quand j'arrive chez nous je
suis déprécies à morter puis j'ai perdu
un ami en fait j'ai su ce matin que mon
ami s'est enlevé la vie
personne ça ben je savais qu'il était
pas heureux mais il y a personne qui
savait à quel point c'est ça me ramené à
ça puis il y a quelqu'un dans ma famille
aussi qui a déjà fait une tentative qui
est vraiment ça à l'hôpital puis qui
était plugué de partout
parce que elle avait de la misère avec
l'intimidation plutôt puis on dirait de
lire des commentaires comme ça c'est pas
que ça me frustrer moi ou que ça me
faisait de la peine mais ça allait me
chercher dans le sens que il y a
beaucoup trop de monde autour de moi qui
ont vécu ça puis qui ont pas été capable
de prendre la critique c'est moi je suis
capable ça va mais j'étais comme
sérieusement faite attention à ce que
vous dites je sais pas c'est pas la
critique rendu là c'est juste de la
méchanceté prendre la même chose
je la notion de progrès tu parlais moi
je suis vraiment intrigué par
commencer les cinq années que tu as
passé en prison
qui t'accrochait genre tu avais tu
mettais quelque chose justement qui
étudiait à chaque jour je vais essayer
un genre de but un genre de thé de
justement de quelque chose que tu peux
progresser ou bien c'était vraiment
juste 5 ans de comme on va animation
non non
je l'ai dit souvent mais on va aller
plus en profondeur que ça mais en gros
ma famille ma famille c'était sur quoi
je m'accrochais à 100%. ok
j'ai dit souvent aussi je savais pas eu
ma famille certains que je serai pas ici
aujourd'hui puis je dis pas ça pour être
dramatique le message je l'aurais pas
été capable
mais sinon
mettons la première année j'ai trouvé
vraiment Rohff parce que justement je
savais pas quand est-ce que je retourne
chez nous j'étais avec du monde que
j'arrivais pas à comprendre où c'était
pas j'avais dit j'avais pas rien qui me
rappelait chez nous c'était juste toute
l'inconnu c'était pas mon langage
et puis je me suis comme tournée vers la
bouffe puis j'ai pris j'en ai une
vingtaine de livres la première année
puis j'ai tout un ticket quelqu'un que
j'ai eu des troubles de poids et puis
être un petit peu plus charnue ça moi je
suis pas heureuse dans mon corps j'étais
pas grosse là mais moi il y a un certain
poids que je sais que je suis
confortable puis je passerai pas à si je
lui trouve alimentaire j'avais expliqué
dans le livre ça me ramènera pas vers ça
que je fais attention encore aujourd'hui
mais mais à part ma famille je pense que
le fait que j'ai lu quand même beaucoup
de livres
faut que tu dises ok tu es ta même place
à toutes les jours tu te réveilles à
mémoire à tous les jours tu manges à
mémoire à tous les jours tu vas
travailler en mémoire tous les jours tu
appelles ta famille à 20h c'est
tellement routinier
que c'est comme si ton cerveau il
devient un peu engourdi un moment donné
jusqu'à tant qu'il y a un changement
j'ai changé de prison 4 fois que c'était
de recommencer à zéro à 4 fois puis
j'avais donc du monde qui m'aimait pas à
cause de ce que j'ai l'air puis le monde
déjà jaloux puis il y avait ça doit être
particulière
ouais mais je dirais pour les
particuliers
mais pour les clics c'est un peu comme
d'un film dans le sens que souvent
toutes les asiatiques vont sortir
ensemble elle est latino mais c'est pas
c'est pas comme d'un film comme il y a
personne qui regarde de côté là c'est
correct c'est juste que tu te mêles pas
trop moi je m'entendais super bien avec
les Vietnamiens je sais pas pourquoi
j'adore vraiment leur mentalité puis aux
autres croit beaucoup en Bouddha puis
c'est vraiment une belle religion en
tout cas
maintenant voilà attendez sportif j'ai
créé un peu le groupe de sportifs si tu
veux j'avais comme il y avait eu un
espèce de concours de begus Closer entre
belenfant les officiers avait mis ça en
place parce que les femmes et les hommes
mettent quand il y avait besoin
d'extérioriser mais il s'entraînait puis
aux autres il y avait des jeunes mais
nous les filles ils mangent
95 % de la population en prison sortait
avec un une moyenne de 30 livres de
surplus de poids après en sortant dans
le fond
qui avait mis ça en place puis moi j'ai
travaillé dans un gym avant tout cela il
y a très longtemps j'ai déjà fait des
diatts puis tout ça les filles moi
j'avais commencé à m'entraîner puis à
courir puis à faire comme des workouts
se joindre à moi puis à un moment donné
quand le Biggie est sorti mais les
filles étaient quand même
comme comment faire si c'était genre
celle qui parle le plus de poids en le
faisant bien aller recevoir genre un
paquet de de Heart work il y avait quand
même des pinceaux puis la peinture mais
je pense que les filles elles faisaient
plus pour la compétition dans le sens
que c'était un competition mais mais
c'est pas pour la faire de quoi mais
plus pour moi
j'ai réussi quand même à c'est ça je
m'accrochais à ça aussi quand je me
disais j'ai pas grand chose mais au
moins j'ai du monde que je peux aider
ici c'est peut-être des amis pareil au
travers de tout ça
j'ai peut-être gardé contact avec deux
personnes depuis que je parle encore
aujourd'hui qui sont rencontré beaucoup
de monde mais c'est surprenant c'est
quatre prisons puis mais c'était tout
dans le dans un état mais c'était dans
des villes différentes mais c'est
souvent les mêmes qui reviennent ça
c'est vraiment triste c'est gros du N9
de même personne c'est puis au début je
m'intéressais pas tant à savoir pourquoi
il est rentré puis sortait ça me
frustrer plus que d'autres choses
[Rires]
ça aussi ça te fait comprendre des quand
tu vois pas l'envers du décor le titre
au Canada oui s'il y a une fusillade à
Montréal que quelqu'un qui a perdu la
vie on n'est pas protégé de tout mais
quand même des pays qui sont pas mal
plus payés que où est-ce qu'on est fac 4
tu vois la vie de d'autres gens
puisqu'on vécu puis il y en a que
c'était de l'abus il y en a que c'était
des viols dans leur famille c'est des
des membres de leur famille qui
faisaient ça il y en a qui ont grandi en
voyant leurs parents comme une des
crimes pour être capable de manger
le même paternité puis je me suis même
intéressé à ça il faut que ça te fait
comprendre que tu es pas si mal dans ta
peau même si c'est en prison enfin tu
sais je pense de m'intéresser à
l'histoire des autres puis avoir que
c'est pas si pire que ça puisqu'il y a
peut-être moyen que je m'en sorte et ça
compte vrai j'essayais ton cerveau il
est vraiment fort c'est fou comment tu
peux t'adapter à toute vitesse comme
quand je dormais chez Claudia car on a
commencé à écrire du livre à la punch
chambre d'inviter en tant que tel mais
elle avait un matelas gonflable qu'on
gonflé puis que je dormais dans son
bureau parce que mal que je dorme sur
12 pouces d'épée moi j'étais comme
tu comprends pas à quel point je
pourrais dormir à terre
ça te fait apprécier des choses que tu
as pas jamais apprécié parce que tu as
pas connu le contraire c'est c'est
l'ultime clash aussi avec ce que toi tu
recherchais avant qu'il te la vie de
luxe
de fucking polluxe
mais c'était luxe pour non c'est pas le
bon mot mais je veux dire c'était ouais
parce que considérant les autres pays
que j'ai été ça aurait pu être pas mal
pire et puis là je considère jamais fait
de prison au Canada mais je pense que
c'est un peu semblable
avec des drops et puis ça leur aurait pu
être pire là
non plus non plus facté plus que tu
progresses moins que c'est difficile
puis plus que tu habites dans des
endroits un petit peu plus luxe là si tu
veux
le seul contact que beaucoup de monde
sûrement avec une prison pour femme
c'est Orange is the new black
fantastique
mais je pense que oui ça peut ressembler
relativement à l'abri faudrait je le
regarde j'ai jamais regardé ça mais
mais parce que toi maintenant tu rentres
là puis il va avoir probablement des
couples lesbiens qui étaient déjà qui
étaient formés maintenant toi tu rentres
là en ayant l'air de ce que tu as l'air
probablement qu'il y a du monde qui font
genre
le vécu je pense le
monde ils se font des idées c'est pas ce
qu'on pense que je regarde la blonde de
l'autre puis moi je fais juste penser à
ma mère comme ça
peut-être que j'étais dans l'une je sais
pas mais j'étais tellement pas dans
cette Viber mais tu sais de
on dirait que tout le monde veut
tellement être beau ici puis là-bas je
voulais pas là-bas je me disais
peut-être je pourrais me raser les
cheveux
que j'aimerais ça pour sembler à ça
aujourd'hui le parce que ça tout ça
c'est une nuit là-bas c'est pas ton
avantage
qui venait d'Australie qui était belle
là et puis à toutes les fois je voyais
la même affaire que ce que moi j'avais
vécu c'est poche c'est vraiment pas
intimider là-bas
à ma place parce que moi mettons à 22h
je connaissais juste le paraître dans le
sens que c'était un atout pour moi le
facache une en prison
c'est les gardes masculins je l'écrouais
pas mais un film je me disais que je
rentre mais un cellule c'est où je me
suis fait tomber dans ma place vraiment
vite
je veux pas te faire ramasser là parce
que ça ira pas un bon un bon temps ici
là fait que tu peu à peu j'apprenais
c'était quoi les politiques quoi faire
quoi ne pas faire à qui parler
encore là c'est l'adaptation tu sais tu
peux pas tout savoir puis j'avais jamais
fait de prison de ma vie fait que
c'était complètement nouveau pour moi là
mais
ouais c'était pas facile tu en parles un
petit peu sur le Podcast avec Étienne
mais
il me semble que la journée ou est-ce
que tu sors ça doit être un feeling
incroyable débile incroyable puis tu dis
que les gardes étaient comme content
pour toi aussi le ouais
le dernier neuf mois j'étais il y a pas
ça
des unités indépendantes qui sont tout
comme la grosse clôture avec la prison
puis que les trois petites maisons en
dehors de la clôture qui est comme sur
la rue si j'avais voulu je porte par
dessus puis je m'en bas c'était vraiment
pour les les prisonnières qui étaient en
confiance là que nous mais je dis qu'il
nous faisait confiance parce qu'on avait
eu un bon comportement tout ça puis je
savais que ça ça s'enlève ça pendant
toute ma sentence j'ai vraiment fait le
plus attention possible pour témoigner
avec les bonnes personnes parfois mettre
dans le trouble j'ai travaillé tout le
long parce que je savais que ça c'est un
option peut-être à la fin puis je
voulais pas le manquer parce que j'étais
plus capable d'être là
avec la dernière fois ça s'est bien
passé puis je me rappelle ça aussi j'en
ai parlé dans le livre dans le fond mais
la libération conditionnelle là-bas
c'est pas donné faut que tu prouves que
tu es prête à te retourner dans société
surtout pour les Australiens mais même
pour les gens qui venaient d'un autre
pays il fallait que
il regarde mettons tout de ton dossier
puis il regarde ton comportement
aujourd'hui puis ça demande c'est à
votre refaire la meilleure façon qu'elle
a fait
puis John le monsieur il s'appelait puis
à Mamie vient me voir puis il dit j'ai
reçu une lettre du bureau de
libérationnel puis ils sont pas sûr que
tu retourneras pas faire la même affaire
parce qu'il dit dans le fond ton mode de
vie il paraît comme
ça retourne dans ma place dans le sens
que tu étais d'une bonne famille tu
travaillais tu avais des
bonsoir en même temps
je peux pas croire qu'ils vont peut-être
me garder ici c'est parce qu'ils sont
pas convaincus tant que finalement je
suis arrivé dans ma chambre j'ai pondu
une lettre je pense à une demi-heure
j'ai comme vider mon cœur et puis je
l'ai mis dans le livre le moment pour
aller mais c'était comme
j'ai j'ai fait beaucoup de rétrospection
j'ai travaillé j'ai eu des livres ma
famille me supporter tout le long je
reparle plus à personne
c'est de qui avait été inclus dans tout
ça et puis tout qu'est-ce que j'ai
appris je l'ai mis sur papier et puis je
l'ai envoyé puis j'étais comme s'il vous
plaît mon Dieu puis John il m'a rappelé
peut-être une semaine après puis il m'a
dit tu m'as donné le système que je m'en
allais chez nous faire ça ça a été un
gros releaf mais je me rappelle
j'ai mis des photos aussi de ça dans le
livre mais je m'étais fait un calendrier
il me restait trois ans à faire que
c'était comme 12 mois par ligne
puis le matin je me suis réveillé était
comme
6h puis j'ai dit bye à tout le monde
puis cette journée il faisait tellement
beau qu'il faisait comme pas chaud pas
froid de super bien dehors puis je me
rappelle j'étais juste assis sur le bas
si je pouvais vous le dessiner je vous
le ferai là mais où est-ce qu'on était
tellement beau c'était juste la verdure
dans le fond des arts des plantes il y
avait des jardins puis j'entends les
oiseaux il y avait pas de son à part les
oiseaux qui chantaient puis j'étais
assez avec mon café puis j'étais comme
je m'en vais chez nous genre aujourd'hui
je sors c'est pas réel ça a pas pire
manière
l'officier qui était là tout le temps
c'était la même femme elle sort elle
sort dehors et comme j'étais comme ouais
j'ai ramassé mes affaires puis aller
ouvert la gate puis on a marché vers la
prison
comme une grosse porte de garage et
ouvre la porte de garage tu continues
jusqu'en haut plus tu rentres dans la
place où est-ce que tu as dans le fond
moi ma mère elle m'avait envoyé du linge
par la poste pour que je puisse sortir
un autre couleur que vert puis j'avais
ce sac là qui m'attendait sur le
comptoir et comme si je choisis
qu'est-ce que tu veux
puis je me rappelle je suis allé dans
salle d'essayage pour me changer puis
elle était là
que c'est plus un problème le fait que
je me change devant elle peut être comme
indiqué ce que tu veux faire avec ton
linge vert
fais ce que tu veux que ça le plus
jamais revendre ça le matin de vie puis
j'ai mis mon linge il y avait pas de
miroir mais juste de sentir un tissu
différent que ce que tu portes pendant 5
ans des pantalons plus ajustés
je fais comme voyons donc et puis je
suis sortie puis là il faut que tes
papiers de sortie tout ça puis les
officiers cachent arriver pour partir
comme are you really God oui
mais ils connaissent ça fait longtemps
qui te voit qui connaissent ton histoire
on dirait ils vivent un peu avec toi
sainte avec toi mais je pense qu'il
savait que c'était un One Time le genre
j'amène que je referai un affaire de
même puis il était il y avait l'air
sincèrement content de me voir passer
puis c'était vraiment spécial comme
feeling puis après ça c'est des agents
de
l'immigration qui qui m'ont amené dans
une vanne c'est une vanne ben normale
puis on est arrivé au centre de
détention j'étais censé rester là
finalement ils m'ont déjà tu restes pas
ici assez longtemps parce qu'on va aller
dans deux jours enfin qu'on doit avoir à
l'hôtel
ouais mais moi j'ai jamais entendu
parler de personnes qui allaient à
l'hôtel après puis finalement on est
arrivé puis je m'attendais à un motel on
va se dire j'étais comme je sors de
prison là puis finalement ça ressemblait
je pourrais ça ressemble à ton hôtel à
Montréal vraiment toute vitrée le 9 9 là
du marbre à terre j'étais là c'est sûr
qu'ils sont trompés de place c'est
impossible
avec le déjeuner est servi jusqu'à 11h
demain matin j'ai comme quoi ah non mais
je dis pas ça ouais mais je le croyais
pas là et puis moi j'avais mon ancien
téléphone puis j'avais un nouveau
téléphone que mon avocate m'avait laissé
puis là il montre comment 23e étage puis
c'était tout c'était un étage réservé
pour des prisonnières qui sortaient avec
toutes les portes c'est comme des
appartements en fait parce que tu
rentres tu avais la cuisine un salon
puis tu avais un couloir là ça reste
dans le même prix ta chambre mais c'est
neuf là c'était une vue absolument
incroyable de de Sydney
puis là je rentre là-dedans j'étais
comme est-ce que ça moi la madame a dit
oui
tout le temps parce qu'il faut qu'on
soit capable de devoir puis à toutes les
demi-heure fallait
puis après ça c'était juste d'essayer de
se connecter sur l'Internet ça marchait
pas plus finalement amené un laptop que
je me suis connecté sur Internet puis
j'ai réussi finalement à convaincre la
madame pas j'arrivais pas à ouvrir
j'avais plus rien pas de courriel rien
rien puis le ça après genre 5h que
j'étais assez au comptoir désespéré la
madame va me dire garde je vais te
prêter mon téléphone mais faut pas que
tu en parles puis elle dit tu as 30
secondes enfin que le genre j'appelle le
numéro à maman je commence
mon père m'avait déjà créé un courriel
enfin que je dis appelle papa le mot de
passe
ouais puis le jour mon courriel j'ai des
courriels de mon père puis de ma soeur
enfin blablabla ça c'était sorti c'était
comme juste un trop plein de d'émotions
absolument incroyable que genre je
souhaite à tout le monde de louer une
fois ma situation mais c'était la
première fois que tu allais sur
l'Internet depuis 5 ans
présente en filament à bord mettons
je peux même pas imaginer parce que
encore une fois on dirait on dirait que
genre moi c'est pas ma mini échelle mais
genre de recevoir un seul pour la
première fois comme trois mois je savais
comme quoi faire avec moi
Éric Salvail et comme gang maintenant
je sais pas j'ai commis un état
des nouvelles mais j'avais vraiment pas
la même vision pas en toute et puis
quand c'est toi qui est aux nouvelles
versus quand tu lis les nouvelles tu
sais jamais qu'est-ce qui est vrai qu'il
est pas vrai tu lis comme moi mais
écoute mais quand c'est sur toi je me
disais ah c'est sensationnaliste en
Tabaret ils font leur job c'est bien
correct si je dirais il faut qu'il faut
que tu sortes des histoires pour que ça
soit attrayant à l'oeil pour tout le
monde puis je peux fâché contre les
nouvelles mais j'avais comme un espèce
de
better dans ma bouche je me dis je veux
même pas savoir ce qu'on va dire sur
toute le reste de la planète on peut ils
font leur job c'est correct sauf qu'il
reste qu'on peut se questionner sur la
nature de l'objectif de la job c'est
maintenant qui joue les codes puis les
codes sont dictés par un désir du monde
qui lit je comprends sauf que on peut se
questionner quand même sur l'éthique
puis la façon que c'est fait je pense il
y en a qui sont en plus
moi j'ai eu ma dose de journaliste
il y en a qui qui sont que ça va pas
faire la part des choses qui prennent
une nouvelle sur le coin d'une table qui
cherche même pas les sources qui disent
n'importe quoi qui font des clics
énormes tu sais qui ont aucune rigueur
journalistique qui ils se disent des
journalistes sur les journalistes
c'est les gens qui lisent les nouvelles
qui prennent ça pour du cage sont tous
coupables je veux dire jusqu'à tant que
ça soit tout ton tour on a été aussi à
on était aussi on a on a appris à
regarder quelque chose puis prendre pour
ce que c'est carrément tu sais pas moi
le monde regarde moi puis j'ai juste
faire une cruche qui importait la drogue
tant que c'est peut-être pour ça qu'à
l'intérieur c'est du cerveau de la
petite madame
c'est pas mal au courant que c'est pas
ça
mettons pour rester dans le thème de la
prison après avoir fait ça pendant cinq
ans
mais c'est quoi ton
opinion ça à la prison ça marche tu
après toi
cheminée grâce à la prison c'est juste
le temps c'est juste c'est
l'avoir vu de l'intérieur c'est une
bonne manière selon toi
pour que les gens puissent se
réhabiliter
c'est dur à dire parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens que j'ai côtoyé que je
sais qui reviendront jamais puis il y a
beaucoup de gens que j'ai côtoyé qui ça
fait depuis qui ont 13 ans qui font la
prison et le narcissique
je pense que ça dépend de ton milieu de
où est-ce que tu viens puis oui c'est
sûr que c'est une belle toutes les
filles qui ont ce qui était en prison
avec moi m'ont dit oh non j'étais carré
là tu es plus jamais mais des fois ils
sortent puis ils n'ont pas qui ont pas
eu le choix de commettre un crime tu as
toujours le choix malheureusement tu en
as qui ont pas de famille ils n'ont pas
les outils ils connaissent pas les
outils ils n'ont pas de téléphone
peuvent pas s'acheter un téléphone non
pas d'argent
où est-ce que tu vois après
l'accompagnement des détenus après ou
des anciens détenus sur une autre
affaire justement des programmes en
Australie mais je pense pas que c'est
assez pour toute la population qui fait
de la prison c'est puis je sais pas
comment ça c'est un autre chose que je
voulais regarder pour le Canada voir tes
mettons les femmes quand ils vont en
cours au Canada est-ce que c'est pas
tout le monde qui ont la famille qui
vont leur envoyer du linge pour il y en
a plein qui se présentent qui sont
habillés comme leur ratés nous autres on
avait un programme c'était déjà super
c'est des petites madame qui travaille à
l'église qui venaient porter des des
ballots de linge pour que les filles
puissent se mettre quelque chose d'essai
pour aller en cours devant le jeu c'est
pour représenter leur cas mais ici je
sais pas c'est toutes les affaires la
même que éventuellement je vois je vais
me lancer là-dedans puis regarder c'est
quoi le système carcéral au Canada
mais oui c'est c'est une excellente
forme de réhabilitation dans le sens que
t'as pas le choix de te poser des
questions quand tu vas là-bas tu as pas
le choix de faire une rétrospection tes
tester à toutes les jours sincèrement là
tout tout en mode
qu'est-ce que tu ressens c'est pas une
place que tu peux montrer tes émotions
tant que ça c'est pas une parce que tu
peux il y en a qui le font mais moi je
sais que c'est pas la solution de de
d'envoyer chien un garde
un peu toutes les émotions tu t'es mis
un peu dans une bouteille tu fermes le
bouchon puis j'ai l'impression que une
chance que j'ai traité ça quand je suis
revenu quand j'ai l'impression que
c'était un peu comme quand il met un
mentos dans une bouteille de papier là
c'est c'est proche de péter fait que
j'ai fait la bonne chose mais oui c'est
le mode réhabilitation parce que
justement je pense la meilleure façon de
savoir
quelque chose c'est pas de savoir
quelque chose mais
tu sauras pas si tu es capable de vivre
sans ton téléphone si tu as jamais pas
ton téléphone c'est avec des fois il
faut que tu vives le contrat de quelque
chose pour pour analyser puis comprendre
c'est que la prison toutes tes
privilèges sont enlevés tu peux pas
appeler ta famille quand tu veux tu sais
c'est maintenant une à deux fois par
jour puis ça coûte quand même cher le
faire les appels Australie Canada et
c'était pas tutoriel en fait à part
toi-même puis un peu de linge puis déjà
à qui parler que tu as pas grand chose
en commun au bout de la ligne tu sais
c'est pour ça que je dis je pense que
tout le monde devrait vivre une semaine
qui sont déprimés de tout
puis après ça tu reviennes si tu as pas
changé avec ça il y a pas grand chose
qui va te faire changer l'envie
malheureusement tu vas être comme pris
pour être la personne qui était puis
mais je pense que tout le monde devrait
l'essayer sincèrement tout le monde que
je connais que fait la vie passionnant
là
une retraite de silencieux
pendant 11 jours tout le monde que je
connais qui est faite
j'imagine pour vrai j'imagine puis de
pas parler en plus c'est une chose de
faire du yoga pendant un jour mais tu
peux pas parler la méditation
complètement différent
moi je serais vraiment Dante d'essayer
ça c'est parce que je j'ai jamais pas
parlé pendant un jour mais de justement
pas avoir de distraction puis qu'en plus
il faut que tu sois en silence s'il y a
pas meilleur méditation que que ça dans
la vie puis même le monde il me dit
souvent moi méditer mais pourquoi toi tu
parles de ton silence pendant une
demi-heure et puis juste passer le monde
sont tellement ils ont il y a une peur
bleue de se poser des questions ou de
faire face à eux-mêmes tu sais c'est con
là mais c'est vraiment la meilleure
thérapie au monde c'est pas pour
tout le monde conseille la méditation
pour guérir quelque chose souvent c'est
vers ça qu'on se tourne ou genre le
lipides ou tout est en silence tout le
temps c'est souvent c'est ça
rentrer en prison ça doit être un choc
incroyable c'est pas on a parlé tantôt
mais sortir d'un prison ça doit être un
choc aussi parce que le tout est nouveau
un peu réapprendre à vivre normalement
non non c'est pas aussi pire que je
pensais côté dans le fond là honnêtement
avec vous autres il y a rien qui a
changé à part des gens qui ont eu des
enfants c'est comme ça c'est vraiment
comme chose je me sentais quand je suis
revenu je suis comme mais ce qui je
pense qu'il est plus troublant c'est que
moi j'avais l'impression que j'avais
zéro Avancé puis que là je courais dans
une boule comme les souris là j'avance
pas j'essaye j'essaye j'essaye je pense
pour ça un peu j'ai fait une dépression
parce que
j'arrivais pas à mettre une pause puis à
traiter toutes les affaires que j'ai
vécues pendant 5 ans j'en ai pas parlé à
personne ouais toutes les frustrations
de tous les jours que j'ai retenu j'en
ai pas parlé
puis je suis arrivée ici puis j'ai fait
la même affaire ma mère me disait
comment ça va je suis comme ah oui ça va
ok ça allait pas pendant toute la
j'ai essayé de retravailler moi j'étais
en confinement pendant deux semaines
mais après ça deux semaines là j'ai
recommencé à travailler tout de suite ma
belle-mère m'avait donné une job et puis
je suis arrivé à au travail puis mon
cerveau retenait aucune information
quand j'ai aucune comme le gars me
former
puis c'est comme si mon cerveau tombait
dans l'une attendait
puis après une semaine je suis allé voir
ma après la première journée ou 2e
journée j'étais arrivé dans le bureau ma
belle-mère à broyeur j'ai dit sérieux je
me sentais tellement mal parce qu'elle
m'a donné une chance si je vous dise pas
tout le monde qui m'a engagé là j'étais
comme je veux pas de décevoir mais je
peux pas je suis pas capable je me
rappelle de rien puis à moi juste pris
dans ses bras il y a 2009 c'est vraiment
normal ce que tu vis qui a dit c'est je
t'ai donné une job parce que tu voulais
la job et je t'aurais jamais
de recommencer à zéro puis surtout que
il y avait plein de monde à qui je
voulais parler mais je savais pas
c'était quoi l'opinion des gens sur moi
puis encore aujourd'hui des fois je suis
gêné d'aller voir le monde que je croise
comme un je la connais mais parce que tu
sais pas ce que le monde en pensait de
toi pendant tout ce temps-là c'est pas
si mon frère comme ça va non ça me
rejoint pas ce que tu fais ou elle veut
faire ça aussi c'était Rohff de tout le
temps te demander je peux dessus aller
parler ou je vais me faire rejeter ou
sortir en public ça c'était un autre
affaire je savais pas si j'allais sortir
en public tout le monde allait se
tourner enfin comment mon lieu mais
norberge tu sais parce que si honteux ce
que j'ai fait pendant longtemps j'ai
vraiment pas être puis encore
aujourd'hui je suis pas fière de moi de
ce que j'ai fait mais dans le sens je me
suis j'ai constamment eu un sentiment de
culpabilité c'est
même la première soirée que mes amis
m'ont amené manger au restaurant un
petit resto bien normal avec une
terrasse fallait comme passer devant la
terrasse pour rentrer dans le resto puis
je disais au fait tout mon regard tout
le monde me regarde plus vite et comme
maintenant il y a personne qui se
regarde si tu regardes c'est peut-être
parce que tu es belle aujourd'hui tu
t'es il m'avait tout arrangé maquiller
tout ça
fait cinq ans
mais ça ça a été dur pour le moral
vraiment beaucoup mais je pense
j'ai juste pas j'ai juste fait tout à
l'enverser mieux ou est-ce que je suis
vraiment prête à recommencer à
travailler je faisais ce que la société
veut que tu fasses et tu travailles tu
sois un bon citoyen qui a été au lieu de
prendre un step back puis vraiment
savoir si je t'ai rendu là
tu disais que tu voulais dans le futur
faire peut-être des conférences
peut-être des apparences parler
peut-être à des gens des jeunes qui ont
des difficultés
parce que ça fait des années que j'en
parle en fait quand j'appelais ma mère
au téléphone en Australie était comme
dit qu'elle se faire maintenant je vais
faire les conférences je veux faire les
conférences je veux apprendre aux gens
ce que je viens de vivre
puis j'ai déjà fait pas à quoi ça
ressemble les réseaux sociaux mais c'est
sûr ça c'est pas amélioré puis
effectivement j'en ai eu la preuve quand
je suis revenue puis j'ai déjà parlé
avec quelqu'un qui travaille qui est
comme chef à la DPJ puis on a déjà
commencé juste pour dire la rencontre la
semaine prochaine facture ça maintenant
je commençais par le livre puis je
voulais voir la réception des gens par
rapport au livre puis voir si j'étais
capable d'aider par avec mes paroles
puis Claudia
a reçu transmettre mes paroles sur une
page incroyablement bien puis tout le
monde me dit qu'on a l'impression qu'il
lit moins que c'est moi qui l'a écrit
enfin pour ça je suis vraiment contente
puis le livre vient une super belle
réception puis ça c'est vraiment tout en
son honneur le oui c'est mon histoire
mais c'est quelqu'un d'autre l'avait
écrit d'une façon différente peut-être
ça aurait pas passé de la même façon
mais le livre moi comme prouvé qu'il y
avait quelque chose à faire avec ça et
puis que les gens veulent apprendre mes
leçons que j'ai appris ou sont ouverts à
faire une rétrospection parce qu'il y a
plein de filles qui me après moi je les
ai là puis à manif il fallait que je
dépose le livre puis je réfléchisse
parce que ça me faisait pas tu me
faisait penser à peine à faire c'est
vraiment ça que je voulais je me suis
dit un livre c'est une chose puis c'est
un peu pour ça je voulais faire le livre
parce que j'aurais pu faire un
documentaire film Mon ever mais je me
suis tout en dit tout a été par rapport
au paraître quand c'est à mon histoire
c'est puis je voulais pas que ça soit ça
cette fois-ci enfin je me dis si je fais
un documentaire puis je parle à la
caméra le monde va être peut-être
distrait puis passer des commentaires
sur ce que j'ai là ce jour là tandis que
si les un livre mais tu peux juste
centrer sur ce que j'ai à dire puis
après pour ça je faisais les podcasts
aussi pas je me disais c'est pas un
entrevue télé
les conférences pour moi c'est c'est les
jeunes ont moins tendance à lire aussi
ces temps-ci là c'est gros des podcasts
ou je me suis si je peux les rencontrer
en personne puisqu'il me parle de deux
autres puis qu'on se pose des questions
aussi puissant je pense que ça ça peut
faire un bel impact ça aussi j'aurais
aimé ça avoir quelqu'un qui me disait ça
quand j'étais jeune je me suis dit
de super inspirant
bien je pense que ce qu'il faut pour
comme faire subiter loin d'être
par rapport à ce que c'est passé puis
les images qui étaient écrits
[Musique]